Je m'appelle James, j'ai 17 ans et je suis à peu près sûr d'être
un psychopathe quand j'avais neuf ans, mais ma
main était une friteuse Je voulais
me faire sentir que quelque chose que l'école était en
dessous de moi mais c'était un bon endroit pour l'
observation  et la sélection j'avais un plan
j'allais tuer quelqu'un Hey vu que tu
patinais c'est de la merde merde
je pense que je pourrais tomber amoureuse de lui je
pensais qu'elle pourrait être intéressante à tuer
alors j'ai fait semblant de tomber amoureux d'
elle c'est  bien ce que je pensais probablement qu'il
était gay il a raison
quittons la ville de merde je vais
quand tu viens avec moi ou pas toi je
ne savais pas où nous allions ni quand
j'allais le faire
j'ai frappé mon père  le visage et a volé sa
voiture et cela ressemblait à un bon endroit pour
s'arrêter et la [ __ ] de banane affamée supplémentaire
pour moi tu sembles [ __ ]
qu'ELISA avait des problèmes avec James étant
avec la femme a commencé à me faire sentir des
choses avez-vous déjà eu une chatte  avant
quelle heure tu n'enregistres pas les
moments importants  ce n'est pas arrivé, laissez-moi
voir qu'ils étaient importants quand nous
regardons en arrière, voyez les deux chaussettes une cloche
enlevez votre haut
[Musique]
pensez-vous que ça va exploser ce n'est pas un
film que je pourrais peut-être réparer
Je peux vous pouvez
toujours le réparer pourquoi personne ne s'arrête
probablement parce que vous avez ces
hits il y a des sortes de cinglés sauf / des
cinglés mais vous voulez vivre allez je
vais être tellement foutu si on se fait
assassiner
[Applaudissements]